out of nowhere I got this phone call
from their manager that was just insane
abusive like
threatening bizarre like you know I'm a
drummer I'm used to kind of getting
treated like crap you're at the bottom
of the food chain of the music industry
right you know who what do you call the
guy that hangs out with musicians the
drummer right so I'm used to crappy
phone calls this was like an
Annihilation it was crazy I got one for
you what do you call a what do you call
a drummer with no girlfriend homeless
there you go so many good got hold on
hold on I got one what's the difference
between a moose and the mighty mighty
bossones what is it that moose has the
horns in the front and the in
the
back there you you said something when
you were working on Kimmel Dicky like
and this is right along with what you're
saying that like Disney came in and they
said everyone has to get this medicine
and everything I know about the medical
industry is you go to a doctor they give
you medicine that's tailored for you
they wouldn't say like your doctor
wouldn't say every this I'm going to
prescribe you a medicine for every human